- I asked him about his
first performance ever,
what do you remember about yours?
- Ooh, so I started off
doing singing competitions,
as you know,
- [Kelly] Oh!
- and the last time, we talked about,
it was fun,
and then when I first did my first show,
at The NorVa in Virginia
Beach, where I'm from,
that was a whole different ballgame.
And I still did a cover at the time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was probably 10 or 11, and I sang
"I Wanna Dance With
Somebody" by Whitney Houston.
- I love that, that was your song.
- Oh, yep,
there I am.
- Yeah.
(Ava and audience laugh)
- I love that though.
That's such a big, fun song.
Everybody loves that song.
- [Ava] Yes, it was my favorite.
I mean,
- Smart.
- who didn't love Whitney?
Who doesn't love Whitney?
- Yeah, absolutely.
And if you don't, you're dumb.
(Ava and audience laughs)
So, you have no ears.
- Oh no, yeah, don't wanna talk to you
if you don't love Whitney.
- Oh yeah, I was like, what,
how do you not like her voice?
I heard that when you were out doing shows
that young though, your grandma
used to pet sit for you,
- [Ava] Oh.
- and maybe she wasn't the best at it.
- This is a funny story actually.
(Ava laughs)
- [Kelly] Isn't it?
- A lot of stories.
Every time my family and
I would go on vacation,
if it was like five days or
seven days, I would leave my,
I had birds, with her, my cockatiels.
- Okay.
- And every time I came back,
the birds would be gone,
and the cage would be open,
- [Seal] Oops.
- and my grandma would be like,
"I just let them out for some air."
(audience laughs)
And I'm like, "But for the third time,
you let them out for some air."
So, every time I got back from vacation,
I would keep getting new birds.
And I think, I don't
think she liked birds.
(Ava and audience laugh)
- Or she just didn't like them caged.
She was like, "They wanna go out."
She was like, "They wanna go."
I just love-
- Maybe that's what it is.
But she really was just like,
"I let them breathe some good fresh air,
and they didn't come back."
(Ava and audience laugh)
- I think the most amazing part is,
you kept allowing her to watch them.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- I know, I know.
I was so young, I stopped
getting them after.
I was like,
- [Kelly] But obviously, she's
not gonna do it this time.
Oh my God.
- Get them again after.
- I love that it's not like a normal pet
that most people pick.
I love that you pick birds.
That's so, well you're a
songbird, that makes sense.
(Ava laughs)
But anything ever gone
horribly wrong on stage,
when you were just like, "Hmm."
- [Ava] So many things.
- Me too.
- So many things.
Almost every time there's something,
'cause you think it's
gonna go the way you plan,
but no, it doesn't.
And I usually have something like a shoe,
probably like, it's kind
of like, I have to wear
multiple socks under
my boots, in my boots.
So, they're really tight.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because I feel like if
they're a little loose,
I'm gonna fall.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I tripped once.
One other time my bra
popped off and thank God,
thank God I had this sparkly top
over the sheer top, but it was sheer.
So, when it popped off I was like, "Whoa."
(audience laughs)
I'm like, "Okay,
hello everybody."
So I'm just gonna stay like
this and no one's gonna know.
- Remind me not to buy that
bra, that specific brand.
- You know, I thought it was cute, but-
- It's different when you have kids.
It's not cute.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
It's different.
I give life to kids.
So what's your moment?
Do you ever have a moment
on stage where you're like,
"Okay, that was not planned."
- Well, I remember doing a show once,
it was part of a festival in Rio.
I think it was, was it
Hollywood Rock or Rock in Rio
or something like that.
- Okay.
- And I remember running onto the stage,
and they had these bright floor lights,
and I tripped, literally
before I sang a single note,
I tripped over the stage,
fell flat over the light,
fell flat on my face, cut up all my leg,
and then had to kind of finish the show,
had to sing for the next hour,
- [Kelly] Oh!
- or so.
- Do you get up, and
address it or do you not?
- Well, back then, I can't, what did I do?
I was a bit shaken, but
I just kind of continued.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And now I'd probably,
I'd take a moment and
make fun of myself and-
- That's 100% me, yeah.
- [Seal] So I'd probably-
- I can't not talk about
it, 'cause it's funny,
(Ava laughs)
falling is funny.
- Exactly, it is funny.
- It's like, "Didn't plan on that,"
but just right on my face in
front of thousands of people.
It totally happened to me too.
Except the microphone was like,
(Kelly warbling)
and like the, yeah,
(Seal laughs)
it was the full moment.
- [Ava] You really never know.
- God thinks that I can
handle a lot, emotionally.
- Oh!
(Ava and Kelly laugh)
Yeah, I was like, "All right, not cool."